des files d'attentes qui s'allonge
inexorablement
des stocks de farine rationnelle et des
boulangeries condamnée à fermer plus tôt
la tunisie manque de pain et la
situation pourrait encore s'aggraver le
pays ne reçoit plus de blé d'ukraine son
principal fournisseur
dans cette file une cinquantaine de
personnes qui espèrent juste pouvoir
acheter du pain aujourd'hui
parfois vous repartez sont d'ailleurs
exactement dans les rues de tunis le
sujet est tellement sensible que ce
boulanger préfère témoigner anonymement
hier sa boutique été fermé car depuis
janvier l'état ne lui a livré que le
quart de la farine qu'il reçoit
d'habitude on travaille le matin
de farine williams ont
bien sûr on a par mois
aujourd'hui on a 35 seulement
alors cette mère de famille écume les
boulangeries mais ici aujourd'hui plus
de baguettes normal seulement des
baguettes à la semoule beaucoup plus
cher pour une famille
nombreuses c'est très coûteux après la
baguette
ce monde a transformé les
250000 est maintenant à quatre formules
et 400 millimes 12 centimes d'euro lieu
de six normalement et pour que tous en
est un peu la vendeuse est obligé de
rationner les clients nrc maximum quatre
baguettes par personne est de retour
chez elle la mère de famille préfère
congelé son pain au cas où il manquerait
totalement
n'est pas disponible
car la pénurie en tunisie ne touche pas
que le pain il manque aussi des huiles
et de farine comme nous le constatons
caméra discrète dans plusieurs magasins
et dans cette petite épicerie de
quartier
puis à de l'huile
non je n'ai pas d'huile pas de farine
même pas deux
ans alors je reviens quand je ne sais
pas il faut attendre
alors ce père de famille se pose des
questions les gens disent que c'est un
problème de maths chinois et de
spéculations aussi
on
sait jamais l'explication pour cet
économiste
avec l'envolée des prix des matières
premières la tunisie déjà ultra endettée
n'a plus l'argent pour s'approvisionner
l'état n'a plus les moyens
d'acheter en grande quantité et donc il
est en train de gérer d'une manière
parcimonie qu en espérant que les prix
redescendent à des niveaux qu'on avait
connu avant et pourtant des céréales il
en pousse en tunisie mais pas de blé
tendre pour la baguette plutôt du blé
dur comme dans ce champ utilisé pour les
pâtes ou la semoule plus rentable pour
les agriculteurs
[Musique]
c'est pas ça qui va réduire notre
dépendance alimentaire en termes de
farine alimentaire c'est parce que là
vous êtes mieux rémunérés là là on est
nettement mieux rémunéré et donc
automatiquement on va plus vers ce blé
dur que vers d'ubs l'état face à la
pénurie de pain ou sont montés une forme
de mécontentement de la population
l'enjeu maintenant pour le président
kaïs ça y est c'est d'éviter que tout
cela ne dégénère en émeutes de la faim
comme dans les années 80